trista mckenzie's on the hill tonight
for the cleveland indians and these are
big starts for guys like mackenzie now
the 1-2 pitch swag and amazing elevated
the fastball and blew it by him and it's
a 1-2-3 first inning for tmac the
indians are coming to bat
[Music]
the home starting pitcher
mr
randy dobneck making his seventh
well his eighth appearance first start
of the year jose ramirez second in the
american league with a dozen homers
adding 265 he's knocked in 25.
the next pitch and he swings and lines
of a set into center so jose ramirez has
a two out single to center
the indians and the ball comes throwing
in and ramirez diving back safely
their ground ball and simmons will fire
across three ground ball outs a harmless
single and a scoreless first for randy
dobneck
[Music]
no score not much of a lead for larnick
mckenzie's next offering
and it's over the inside corner strike
three call
a 91 mile an hour fastball froze
scarborough
[Music]
this is dobneck's 16th career start he's
eight and five
all time as a starter and the 3-2 swing
and a miss and down he goes on a
fastball at 93.
first strikeout for dobneck
here tonight his 12th this season
swag and a miss and downey goes 94 miles
an hour
rob raf schneider will lead off the
third
simmons on deck
and the 2-2 pitch a drive to left field
and deep back it goes deep it goes and
that ball is going a home run
ref snyder's first as a twin to straight
away left field and the twins take a
one-nothing lead on their 60th homer of
the season
in the eighth home run allowed by
tristan mckenzie
and ref schneider
as simmons goes down on three pitches
ref snyder is now hit in six of his
seven games that he's played against the
indians yeah i remember he came up with
new york he hit
he hit the ball hard
chased one in the dirt
and the throw down to first
for route number two back-to-back case
for mckenzie
and dombang off to a good start here
picked up three strikeouts
and other than ramirez's base hit
nothing's left
base is loaded nobody out larnock steps
in
state of mckinsey the first pitch swung
on roll to the right side picked up by
bowers goes perspective for one the
relay back to first gifts away from the
pitcher mckenzie into the camera well
one run scores kepler's going to come in
to score that first one i believe
kiriloff will be pushed across as well
as the ball squirted out of play it's
going to be an outed second base on a
3-6 put out
and a cleveland error will allow the
twins to take a three-nothing lead base
is loaded one out
larnick at third garber at second ref
snyder at first for andrilton simmons
maton right-hander
sets out the belt likes to work inside
and he leaves one off the plate away and
simmons sports it into right for a base
hit base hit for angelton simmons one
run will score as larnick comes home
strong throw from naylor but no chance
at the play station to station baseball
for the minnesota twins and they lead
this game four nothing that'll bring up
josh donaldson
hope mcdonaldson can square one up here
and do some damage will count
3-2
not even close ball four in the twin
steeler run
wow
they'll take it
ref schneider in to score and make it
five-nothing minnesota rbi on the free
pass
kepler started this inning with a walk
0-2
swung on well hit from max kepler into
the right field corner naylor going back
it's over his head and he kisses off the
wall naylor takes it on a big bounce
simmons scores easily a rise will follow
he will score donaldson chugs into third
base and a two run double for max kepler
there's the big two out hit the twins
have been waiting for and it's seven
nothing minnesota
second and third for carol off
he swings and hits this one in the air
to left field it's deep for eddie
rosario eddie's back looks up he'll play
that off the 19-foot high wall donaldson
scores easily into score is kepler it's
a ringing single off the barricade in
left for alex kiriloff
liftoff for kiriloff nine nothing twins
and here comes ceno he drew a walk
earlier this inning
now sano lashes one to the gap in left
center field
carol off to third they're going to wave
him around
and kiriloff
will score with ceno driving in a run
and it's 10 to nothing
and a hard hit ball into left field on
the no two pitch
josh naylor and look at fred neal
putting it down as he goes all the way
to third
indians at the corners with one out
strike three call
a sinking fastball left upstairs but it
frozen for out number two
bouncer right side simmons has it
and it's a scoreless fourth
domneck had to face five men but he
retired three of them and it's still 10
to nothing
and a base hit to right field
hernandez will round second and go to
third
and rosario with a sharp single we're
gonna bring ramirez to the plate with
two men aboard
one hop rocket to rise
five shutout innings for randy dobneck
and a 10-0
[Music]
holds a third donaldson gets another try
out there
and a double play to wrap up the inning
six shutout innings for randy domnach
and a 10 nothing twins lead
luke farrell trying to get out of
trouble second and third two down 2-2
pitch
naylor with a bouncing ball to first
kirloff with a flip
and the indians still cannot dent the
scoreboard
[Music]
the runners will move on the 3-2 pitch
and he strikes him out with a fastball
to end the inning
bottom of the night coming up